one time I was talking to a girl and she
said she went to Coachella and she had
never done Molly and she was like had
her arms up and she was dancing around
and in the Coachella [ __ ] and somebody
came up behind her and wiped [ __ ]
Molly on her face dude hey let me tell
you something okay if somebody ever did
that to me now I've never done Molly
I've never done drugs if somebody ever
[ __ ] snuck some drugs into me I'll
tell you right now I would fight
everyone around me until I was either
dead or high that's how it will go if
you wiped Molly in my mouth everybody
around that person who did that is
complicit I'm fighting everybody I see
until I'm dead or trippin cuz I know
want some trip and I'm not gonna want to
fight everybody right I'll be like I
would that be hilarious to be like
fighting and [ __ ] knees and just if you
were winning just [ __ ] beating the
[ __ ] out everybody haha just high kicks
and [ __ ] plan
and just pop a hot choking people out
and doing arm bars yeah and then more
[ __ ] people come in come on and then
all its own you're just like [ __ ] mmm ah
[ __ ] ah
[ __ ] man is so [ __ ] good the [ __ ]
Papa and then you're fighting and then
you're wrestling but then also it kind
of feels good because people are like
grabbing on you and [ __ ] and you're like
oh god damn it until all of a sudden it
just turns into [ __ ] one more time
got me feeling so free
they got me celebrate celebrate and
dance with me and you're still fighting
a little bit you're like Popeye but
you're like one more time and you're
just sweating so ho yeah is there a
brain huh but if he laughs I oh yeah oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] I've said a brain Papa come on
time somebody's on your back you're just
like [ __ ] you hike them up on your
shoulders and you're like well I'm got
me feeling so free but you got somebody
on your shoulders and you're having a
good time but also you're still kind of
fighting people and then all of a sudden
you just let loose and you're just like
you know what [ __ ] oh yeah timon
celebrate with me and then the beat
drops and you just like yeah
I'm dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
dumb dumb dumb and your [ __ ] bloody
and exhausting your shirts ripped and
you're just like [ __ ] this place
rocks and you just have a blast for
[ __ ] seven hours until all your
spinal fluid is gone that would be that
would be me that would be what I did and
then once I came to and all the [ __ ]
all the guys who were complicit came to
we'd be like dude that [ __ ] rocked that
was one for the ages but if any of you
are ever complicit in putting Molly in
my face again we're doing it all over
again and then look at me and they go
like this oh yeah we are dude and then
we [ __ ] ride off into the sunset said
I'm BAE and then so free and on a setup
bang do a little bit of me and the
credits just wrong as we were off into
the sunset and it's me and the guy from
itto mama tambien like that was like he
was there dude [ __ ] this is what it
see this is what I'm talking about when
I talk about the [ __ ] I don't need I
don't want to go do [ __ ] I don't want to
go when people are like let's go [ __ ]
and check it out when Reno Ohio or
whatever the [ __ ] we are my openers like
we go just go see a [ __ ] Rockies game
whoa dude I don't want to watch guys
play baseball when I can just think a
[ __ ] like that
that's so [ __ ] art to me to think of
a guy getting [ __ ] molly'd in his
face and then fighting until he got high
and then riding off into the sunset bro
what the [ __ ] I'm gonna go watch the
Rockies play the [ __ ] out of here dude